[Musica]
ho sempre sognato di entrare saltando
scusate ma non potevo camminarci e basta
facciamo un esperimento velocissimo vi
domando subito per alzata di mano
quanti di voi sono stati al louvre
fantastico ok unanimità completa
ora il louvre è un database enorme forse
il più grande database della civiltà
umana e contiene opere d'arte manufatti
che vengono dall'egitto dalla
mesopotamia partono dall'inizio della
civiltà umana fino ad arrivare i primi
del 900 fino a gerico diciamo 800 900
ora io sono quasi sicuro che ognuno di
voi nei percorsi al louvre abbia visto
almeno una cosa o almeno si ricordi di
una cosa della monna lisa di leonardo
giusto ogni ognuno di voi che è andato
al louvre è andato a portare omaggio
alla monna lisa
ora non so se facciamo questo piccolo
esperimento state guardando negli occhi
la monna lisa di leonardo ok
cosa avete intorno riuscite non vale per
chi è appassionato di beyoncé e ha visto
il video perché sennò non funziona deve
essere basato su un'esperienza da
visitatore al museo quindi non spoiler a
te che cosa ci affianca ve lo dico tra
un minuto davanti alla monna lisa di
leonardo
cioè se date le spalle alla monna lisa
vedrete questa pittura non passa certo
inosservato né è una pittura di 9 metri
di larghezza per sei di altezza sono le
nozze di cana di paolo veronese una
pittura rinascimentale
ora se osservate bene questa immagine
vedrete che in mezzo alla sala c'è
qualcosa di strano c'è una sedia la
vedete
ok no una sedia nera ora se alzate lo
sguardo
vedrete che nel quadro c'è un altro
elemento di disturbo
notate lo schermo è grande ma magari non
abbastanza tra un minuto numero vedete
che c'è una persona al centro del quadro
per questo sono entrato saltando non
potevano entrare saltando insomma questo
cerchio nello minimi invitava ora
attraverso un salto un salto reale
quindi utilizzando come elemento quello
che di più naturale cioè cioè la forza
di gravità o almeno l'esperienza della
forza di gravità sono a parigi ma al
tempo stesso sono a cana sono nel 2019
anzi chiedo scusa sono del 2009 perché
questa fotografia scattata a ben dieci
anni fa ma contemporaneamente sono nel
rinascimento perché personaggi ritratti
sono vestiti dai costumi rinascimentali
e sono anche al tempo stesso nel nuovo
testamento
all'epoca in cui gesù faceva i miracoli
ora vi dico questo perché con un
semplice salto aumentato questa pittura
e ho fatto un salto temporale anche no
mi sono connesso a più cose a più
dimensioni sono sospeso tra più più
mondi e questa idea di essere sospeso
tra più mondi secondo me è una
prerogativa della nostra generazione
quella dei millennial o comunque quella
che ha vissuto la transizione di fase
epocale tecnologica di internet e dei
cellulari
ora noi in questo caso siamo sospesi tra
il mondo analogico e il mondo digitale
l'abbiamo ripetuto molte volte oggi ma
non so se avete presente quando state
parlando con qualcuno e sentite in tasca
che avete il telefono che vibra capite
che è un messaggio non è una una
telefonata però siete
in una conversazione con un'altra
persona ma dovete rispondere c'è la
tentazione troppo forte quindi
continuate a dire a si sia interessante
poi guardate in basso
guardate il telefono è arrivata vedete
whatsapp ok ti rispondo intanto sicilia
risponde ecco quando fate questo perché
sono sicuro che lo avete fatto
continuiamo a farlo costantemente lo
facciamo e lo faremo sempre di più voi
non siete soltanto di fronte a quella
persona in quel momento
voi siete anche magari in australia a
rispondere al vostro amico che vi sta
chiedendo un informazione o vista
soltanto salutando questa è un iper
connettività dimensionale che in qualche
modo ci entusiasma ma dall'altra parte
rischia un po di confonderci perché
magari perdiamo il discorso poi facciamo
delle figuracce perché non riusciamo più
ad interagire come dovremmo ora quello
che è una novità per noi non è una
novità per le particelle cioè questa
capacità di essere in più posti
contemporaneamente ed interagire con più
cose è una prerogativa delle particelle
lo hanno sempre fatto e sempre lo
faranno loro vivono in una nuvola di
probabilità quantistica e quindi possono
essere in più luoghi e naturale fintanto
che succede succede qualcosa e allora
produce degli effetti ma perché facciamo
fatica in qualche modo a immaginarci di
comportarci come qualcosa di così
primordiale come sono le particelle
perché in qualche modo ci ricordiamo
quello che eravamo ieri cioè elefanti
nella savana che seguono sempre percorsi
lineari alla ricerca dell'acqua dal
punto a al punto b no destruction
ora per chiami millenial o per chi ha
avuto un figlio in anni
i recenti diciamo non troppo recenti
conosce il cartone animato dei pokémon
conoscete i pokémon no si no ora io
immagino che quello che stiamo vivendo
oggi assomigli a una un upgrade come da
una versione basic a di un pokémon a una
versione upgrade e nella questione
magari non so immaginiamo anche a dragon
ball noda normale a super sayan ecco la
la trasformazione che ci aspetta è
quella dell'elefante quantistico
dobbiamo diventare un elefante
quantistico
non so io l'ho visualizzato in maniera
molto banale ma sono sicuro che ci sarà
modo di descrivere in maniera più
vincente questo come lo possiamo fare è
fondamentale immaginare nuove dimensioni
ma è importante tornare alle domande di
base a quelle fondamentali da dove
veniamo e chi siamo
è per questo che quando ci comunicano
che abbiamo scoperto una nuova immagine
di un buco nero tutto il mondo è
affascinato e colpito da questa notizia
perché in situazioni tipo nel big bang
on ei buchi neri che noi siamo stati nel
lontanissimo passato connessi al tutto
quindi io mi occupo di arte
contemporanea ma ho scelto un approccio
interdisciplinare perché avevo il
bisogno di capire meglio che cosa c'è
alla base delle cose le domande della
scienza sono simili a quelle dell'arte
perché entrambe si occupano
dell'invisibile e dubitano che la realtà
che ci circonda assomigli a quello che
vediamo credono che dietro alla realtà
ci sia un'altra realtà una sub realtà le
domande sono che cos'è la materia cosa
sono le particelle cosa sono gli atomi
sappiamo che gli atomi hanno degli
elettroni che orbitano intorno a dei
nuclei fatti di forks grazie alla fisica
teorica e sperimentale sappiamo
sempre di più su come si comportano le
forze fondamentali sappiamo che esiste
uno zoo di particelle che compone un
intero modello standard che il
linguaggio della natura
però sappiamo anche che appunto le
particelle si comportano in maniera
diversa non è che torniamo a casa
andiamo in salotto e diciamo a ciao
particella come stai
cosa stai leggendo un giornale non è lì
la particella la particella non è seduta
su una sedia può essere qui può essere
qui può essere qui può essere qui può
essere qui può essere cui può essere qui
poi lo riempie è in un campo di
possibilità come succede in questa in
questa scultura che ho chiamato dragon
zag uovo di drago in questo caso
potrebbe stare esattamente in un posto
in effetti ci sta è un bronzo una
tecnica di più di 5000 anni fa che però
ha deciso di equipaggiare di un
rivelatore di particelle realizzato in
collaborazione con l'istituto nazionale
di fisica nucleare
ora ogni tanto la scultura e metti un
lampo di luce quando emette un lampo di
luce lo fa non perché come dire ha
voglia di farlo ma perché il rivelatore
che al suo interno capta dei buoni cioè
delle particelle che vengono dalla
stratosfera e le convertono in energia
le convertono in luce visibile
quello che vediamo non è la particella
non è il muone in sé ma è l'interazione
che ha avuto con
il rivelatore
quindi abbiamo imparato che alla base
delle particelle come vediamo nella
scultura quello che vediamo veramente
l'energia però che cos'è l'energia e qui
arriviamo un po la questione
fondamentale tutta la fisica si basa
sull'idea che l'energia non si crea e
non si distrugge ma si conserva tutto
quello che vediamo è un prodotto
dell'energia ma se non si creano non si
distrugge da dove viene l'energia ora
collaborando con la comunità scientifica
e in particolare nel 2009 mandando una
semplice email
ho iniziato un dialogo con carlo rovelli
che magari conoscete ho capito che ho
sentito parlare di viller john arcibaldi
miller che è un pioniere della gravità
quantistica insieme a charles business
ea keep thorne che negli anni 80 alla
fine degli anni ottanta esprime un
concetto straordinario gli dice che alla
base dell'energia c'è l'informazione
però è un'informazione strana non è
l'informazione che conosciamo oggi è
un'informazione che in qualche modo
rappresenta tutte le possibilità di un
sistema
ora se immaginiamo che tutto quello che
ci circonda dalla microscala alla
macroscala è fatta di bit di
informazione come dice wheeler it from
bit
allora non c'è frattura non c'è frattura
tra la microscala tra l'esplosione di
una supernova e per esempio una pittura
del rinascimento
non c'è una differenza tra lo spin di
una particella e una un hard disk che
dissipa calore sulla nostra scrivania
non c'è differenza tra una telefonata su
skype e delle urla nella foresta
d day gibboni oppure le onde
gravitazionali prodotte da un buco nero
e se questo è vero per loro allora è
vero anche per noi
anche noi esseri umani siamo fatti di
informazione e condividiamo informazione
anche internet quindi è una forma di
cody di informazione che ci permette
esperienze diverse ma non dobbiamo
dimenticarci che è come avere a che fare
con dei segnali di fumo o delle pitture
rupestri in un'epoca in cui cerchiamo di
mettere al centro della nostra
esperienza all'essere umano nella
dell'antropocene quello che dobbiamo
secondo me fare è non immaginare di
essere esseri umani che usano
l'informazione e strumentalizzano
l'informazione per ottenere delle cose
ma di essere informazione in movimento
il nostro mondo assomiglia a una specie
di mandalà dove i bit di informazione
sono come granelli di sabbia che restano
intrappolati solo temporaneamente e poi
sono liberi di muoversi e di andare
altrove
solo questi granelli che compongono
questo essere il primo descritto da
calvino nelle cosmi comiche che ha
deciso di saltare per l'appunto fuori
dall'acqua per vivere su uno scoglio le
sue informazioni sono dentro ognuno di
noi proprio in questo momento nel mio
lavoro ho immaginato un linguaggio dove
l'informazione potesse prendere tante
forme e potesse parlare a più pubblici e
potesse andare oltre la disciplina rita
specializzata lo immagino così un altro
riferimento a dragon ball è un drago
cendron 5.0 con con la testa di gravità
quantistica gli occhi di cosmologia
molti messaggera gli artigli di c'era la
medardo rosso il cuore di fisica delle
particelle la coda di quanto un
computing e le ali degli angeli della
madonna del parto di piero della
francesca
grazie
con questo linguaggio si può fare cose
che almeno io ho potuto fare cose che
non mi sarei mai sognato di poter fare
sono finito all'auditorium del cern di
ginevra come esperienza incredibile
potete immaginare a parlare del bacco e
arianna di tiziano a dei fisici
sperimentali durante lo spring
collaboration meeting della nasa e del
fermi telescope
per me è stato un miracolo un vero
miracolo ho parlato del bacco e rand di
tiziano come se fosse un laser come se
fosse un getto di informazione che
viaggia nello spazio aspettando che
qualcuno riceva questo segnale
noi tutti quando andiamo al louvre e
guardiamo un'opera d'arte siamo un
rivelatore che estrae dall'arte
dell'informazione e la traduce nella
nostra vita
per concludere nell'era di internet e
dei social network alle porte di una
rivoluzione tecnologica basata sul sui
computer quantistici e integrati e
l'intelligenza artificiale
stiamo solo adesso iniziando a intuire
quello che può essere una nuova forma di
messaggistica universale quella delle
onde gravitazionali quella della materia
oscura quella dei timidissimi neutrini
che per poter essere ascoltati hanno
bisogno di un'intera stanza di purezza
perché se no non te la raccontano il
segreto sono come i migliori amici in
questo per in questo periodo stiamo
passando da una società basata
sull'elettromagnetismo quella dei nostri
nonni quella che hanno visto e sono
stati sconvolti dalla potenza
distruttiva dell'atomo dalle onde radio
e dai raggi ics e quindi da tutte le
forme di comunicazione basate sullo
spettro elettromagnetico che ancora oggi
stiamo usando in questo momento ecco
immaginate quello che succederà noi nel
prossimo futuro quando potremo
comunicare e inventare una nuova
tecnologia basata su queste altre cose
ora qual è il punto a cosa serve poter
comunicare di più e leggere più
informazioni a 360 gradi
qual è il fine per me il fine e
arricchire la nostra coscienza e capire
profondamente chi siamo e come possiamo
interagire con tutte le cose che ci
circondano la cosa bella è che la
coscienza quando la la maturiamo e de
nos ed è diciamo mia non è solo mia
e nostra perché attraverso la
comunicazione attraverso l'informazione
passa da me a voi
[Applauso]